[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día
vamos a hablar de la inestabilidad
política en Reino Unido tras la dimisión
de la primera ministrada Alice Rush que
sigue ahora pues se lo preguntamos a
Johana Maya ya es profesora e
investigadora del 15 y de la universidad
es gracias a Johana por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 esta mañana de viernes también nos
acompaña en el estudio Rosa Pérez mateu
parte de nuestro equipo periodístico de
nuestra matinal y pues que sigue ahora
Johana
bueno en medio de esta crisis hay mucha
incertidumbre en estabilidad política e
institucional
en este momento se está esperando un
nombramiento rápido de un sucesor
que enfrenta principalmente El desafío
como es obvio de garantizar la
estabilidad macroeconómica del país así
como garantizar la seguridad del bloque
occidental que se está uniendo Para
apoyar a Ucrania resistiendo la invasión
de Rusia y qué podría hacer precisamente
un sucesor de listras para garantizar
esta estabilidad al frente del gobierno
británico que elecciones tiene que
aprender de este breve mandato de la
primera ministra
pues lo cierto es que esta serie de
sucesos y de elecciones frecuentes
dentro del partido conservador está
denotando una crisis de legitimidad del
partido conservador en el país al día de
hoy si los británicos pudieran votar el
30%
más votaría por los laboristas y no por
los conservadores en este momento los
conservadores perderían las elecciones
entonces
ningún candidato conservador
garantizaría legitimidad y estabilidad
ante todo esto Johana yo le quería
preguntar qué pena le interrumpo por por
unas posibles elecciones generales no
evidentemente al partido conservador no
le interesaría unas elecciones generales
porque como él lo está diciendo pues
perdería no el liderazgo de Reino Unido
pero como pueden hacer también los
laboristas para intentar presionar para
llegar a estas elecciones generales que
evidentemente le van a favorecer a ellos
técnicamente dentro de la dinámica del
sistema parlamentario todos los miembros
del parlamento conservadores tendrían
que votar en contra del gobierno y eso
sería políticamente un suicidio entonces
la posibilidad de que eso suceda es muy
baja
los laboristas en este momento están
encabezando las encuestas pero la
probabilidad de que haya una elección
general que sería lo más legítimo y
democrático es muy baja y como usted
bien no comentaba no hay un problema de
legitimidad en el partido conservador
pero precisamente por eso se habla de
este posible retorno de Boris Johnson
porque al final fue un líder que ganó
unas elecciones qué tantas posibilidades
hay de que este regreso Se materialice
pues Boris Johnson goza de una
legitimidad parcial dentro no sólo de
los miembros del parlamento pero los
miembros del partido
el mandato legítimamente democrático fue
otorgado a él pero la mayoría de los
británicos no lo apoyarían en este
momento Si hubiera elecciones generales
así que sería una legitimidad muy
parcializada y pues algunos piensan que
esto sería la hecatombe del partido
conservador ya con la elección del
ISSSTE los medios europeos como la Radio
Nacional alemana anunció desde principio
una tragedia no solo para el país sino
para el continente y para el mundo
porque al final tenemos que tener en
cuenta que Inglaterra tiene un rol muy
importante en la geopolítica
internacional en un momento de guerra en
Europa y su sitio en la otan
debe estar garantizando estabilidad en
vez de convulsión política al interior
del país Johana también muchos analistas
coinciden y aseguran que digamos todos
estos problemas y estén hostilidad
política en Reino Unido no es de hace un
año atrás o meses sino desde que
decidieron salirse de la Unión Europea
qué balance hace entonces que y también
que participación digamos activa ha
tenido este brexit dentro de la
inestabilidad política de Reino Unido
del conservatismo no empieza con la
crisis parlamentaria del covid que
heredó Boris Johnson o el desastre
económico que produjo el stras pero el
brexit ha sido mal observado en las
dinámicas del mercado Global en la
geopolítica global porque ha causado
inestabilidad económica acompañada de
una crisis energética y una masiva
crisis financiera entonces hay una serie
de coyunturas que confluyen como la
crisis del brexit la crisis de las
exportaciones que
ha añadido a las medidas del Mini
presupuesto que anunció Luis Trust y
paradójicamente al mismo tiempo medidas
para gastar 150 mil millones de libras
esterlinas para limitar los efectos de
los consumidores en el aumento de los
precios de la energía fueron castigados
por los mercados y Johana muy
rápidamente para terminar a quien ve más
preparado para sacar al Reino Unido de
esta crisis
Pues dentro de los candidatos posibles
hay varios que tienen una tradición
técnica y de ejecución aunque los medios
castiguen
AK el tubo un buen desempeño como el
canciller de Hacienda o ministro de
hacienda durante la pandemia Penny
morena aunque también pertenece a la la
más radical cherista del partido
conservador podría jugar un buen rol o
la misma suela breakman se renunció un
día antes de litros